all right let's try it again
just just more chewing ah
hot Cheeto girl ASMR does the hot refer
to the Cheetos or to the girl
I can't overstate how much I hate this
didn't expect to I
I would just be not interested in it or
wouldn't move me but I actively hate it
I hate it I can't
I don't want to cut it short because I
want it so gross I can't I can't it's
disgusting
so like one time I remember I was in
college and a buddy of mine who was a
roommate of mine also he comes in and I
had just gotten a big block of chocolate
I said oh hey man here you want some
chocolate it's like oh yeah sure if I
give him a piece of chocolate he sits
next to me on my bed and just right next
to my ear
and I almost rang his Little Neck
[Music]